namasté les amis cette vidéo est une
vidéo annonce dès demain à 8 heures du
matin je serai en live pour qu on médite
ensemble je prends la vie de 8h à 8h45
pour méditer et ensuite de 8h45 à 9
heures on fera un petit débrief et on
discutera ensemble sauf si ça me saoule
et là ça s'arrêtera très vite la partie
des discussions jeudi à la partie
méditation dans cette vidéo on va donc
voir ensemble pourquoi et comment
méditer alors il ya plein de types de
méditation différents nous on va en voir
un ensemble c'est une méditation
annappes ana ana pana satie ça veut dire
la tension au souffle pour le pourquoi
d'abord le but de cette technique s'est
développé son attention au moment
présent
les sources de nos maux de ce qui nous
affecte pas ça va être de l'anxiété de
l'inquiétude de la peur diriger vers le
futur ou du regret de la nostalgie des
choses qui nous empêchent d'avancer de
la culpabilité diriger vers le passé
globalement le passé et le futur sont
les sources de nos maux c'est en tout
cas la vision qu'on va adopter ici on va
donc entraîner notre esprit à revenir au
moment présent à toujours revenir au
moment présent
un petit peu le muscle et on peut voir
ça comme un exercice de fitness si vous
voulez mais pour votre esprit pour le
pourquoi je pourrais aussi parler des
bienfaits de la méditation qui sont
multiples par exemple sur la mémoire ou
par exemple sur la concentration
il ya d'ailleurs un épisode de vox de la
série explained qui a été fait dessus
qui est visible sur netflix je crois qui
est incroyable à ce sujet si j'ai
d'autres sources je voulais mettre en
descriptions alors comment ça marche
maintenant qu'on a vu pourquoi c'est à
dire l'intérêt de revenir au moment
présent parce que c'est celui qui me
permet d'être dans le vrai d'être la
réalité d'apprécier les choses qui nous
arrivait de pas être dans une anxiété
une peur ou non sans regret ni
culpabilité le comment est important
parce que je sais pas à quel point je
vais guider les méditations parce que je
vais méditer en même temps que vous et
donc si vous ne connaissez rien à la
méditation écoutez bien les petits
conseils que je vais vous donner puisque
c'est eux qui vont permettre de vous
mettre à sa pratique
je précise par ailleurs que je suis
absolument pas prof de méditation que
j'ai pas eu de formation méditation
juste fait deux stages de méditation
assez intensif d'une vingtaine de jours
en silence avec mutation du matin
jusqu'au soir et je médite moi même
depuis tous les jours depuis plus d'un
an maintenant
c'est d'ailleurs ça qui était donc ce
truc que je fais tous les jours dont je
vous ai parlé aux dernières résolutions
c'est évidemment à la méditation et ça
fait longtemps que je voulais vous faire
des live comme ça de méditation en tout
cas essayé pendant quelques jours et je
trouve que le confinement s'y prête
merveilleusement bien
l'idc a donc être d'observer un élément
qui nous rattache au moment présent
un élément si possible qu'on a toujours
avec nous et cet élément
ça va être notre respiration on va donc
ça soit encore en tailleur ou bien les
pieds sur le sol on évite d'être
allongée parce qu on a plus de chance de
s'endormir
par exemple et on va observer sa
respiration donc si possible par le nez
l'idée dans cette méditation à la pana
c'est d'observer sa respiration telle
qu'elle est et donc sans l'influent est
donc le but ce n'est pas de calmer ses
inspirations ou de respirer plus vite ou
quoi que ce soit c'est juste d'observer
telle qu'elle est c'est un moment vous
êtes stressé il est possible que votre
respiration soit plus rapide on vous
demande pas de la changer ou demande
d'observer là observait on vous demande
de l'observer tel quel et donc vous
allez porter attention à sa terre qui
rentre et sa terre qui sort et à toutes
les sensations que ça implique autour de
son droit
autre élément important quand je vous
dis d'observer la respiration telle
qu'elle est c'est à dire qu'on va rien
verbaliser va pas se créer des images
mentales
on va pas se dire par exemple voilà je
compte jusqu'à temps et tous les temps
je respire j'inspire etc tout ça on va
pas le faire on va juste observer sa
respiration telle qu'elle est si vous
avez narine gauche et vous avez une
arène boucher c'est pas grave
pas de montre a pas de choses comme ça
ce n'est pas ça la méditation à la pana
on observe les choses telles qu'elles
sont si on veut observer le moment
présent on va l'observer tel qu'il est
sans projection mentale
si je peux me permettre de donner un
autre conseil vous risquez d'avoir froid
parce que pendant longtemps vous n'allez
pas bouger mais n'est pas trop chaud non
plus sinon ça va être désagréable aussi
dans les derniers conseils moi je
recommande pas de méditer sur son lit
par exemple parce que je trouve que on
s'enfonce un peu dans lle du coup ça
fait encore plus mal au dos évidemment
si vous êtes dans une position que vous
trouvez trop inconfortable changer de
position le but là c'est pas de ce fait
mal parfois ça peut être intéressant
justement de ressentir de la douleur et
c'est parce que c'est un outil aussi
mais c'est pas le but ici pendant cette
méditation votre esprit vagabonder il
est possible que vous pensiez à ce que
vous avez à faire dans la journée est
possible que vous pensiez à ce que vous
avez fait la veille
il est possible que vous pensiez à ce
qui vous manque dans cette période de
confinement il est possible que vous
pensiez aux inquiétudes liées à cette
crise sanitaire avec l'amp fait face et
pareil pour moi je vais forcément penser
à la caméra j'ai forcément pensé au fait
que ce soit là j'ai pas l'habitude de
méditer aussi longtemps ça fait
longtemps que j'ai pas mes idées 45
minutes pour être très honnête
donc je vais peut-être voilà je pensais
au fait que ce soit long jeu voilà c'est
normal notre esprit vagabond l'important
c'est qu'en se rend compte qu'on a
vaillamment des camps se rend compte
qu'on se dit mince je suis pas du tout
en train de s'observer ma respiration
banro mais son attention sur sa
respiration sans la moindre culpabilité
ça c'est très important faut pas se dire
j'ai une mauvaise méditation parce que
j'ai pas assez observé ma respiration
etc
faut pas avoir de culpabilité par
rapport à ça les pensées passe comme des
nuages
voilà la vienne et passe etc et quand on
s'en rend compte
on revient sur sa respiration fausse le
donné comme but et comme objectif mais
il faut pas s'en vouloir
si à un moment on pense à autre chose on
ramène juste son attention au moment
présent
du coup il est possible que ça vous
viennent dans la journée parfois que à
des moments vous rameniez votre
concentration sur le moment présent et
c'est peut-être ça qui va vous aider
dans votre quotidien avec la méditation
au delà de ça je trouve que méditer le
matin ça permet un petit peu de voile à
se recentrer sur soi dans le calme être
plus concentré pour la journée qui nous
attend les moines bouddhistes disent que
si vous n'avez pas une heure dans la
journée pour méditer alors vous devriez
méditer deux heures on se retrouve donc
demain matin à 8 heures en live
si cet horaire change s'il ya des
informations par rapport au live ce
genre de choses tout sera en description
de cette vidéo la cette vidéo là ce sera
notre repère parmi ces livres là parce
que les live seront parés au clos des
donc quand on devra discuter ensemble de
l'organisation autour de ces livres là
ça se fera en descriptions ou en
commentaire de cette vidéo là je précise
aussi que vous n'avez absolument pas
venir de 8h à 8h45 méditer si vous avez
envie de méditer dix minutes venir
partir ou même cinq minutes
n'hésitez absolument pas la porte est
grande ouverte
c'est avec plaisir qu'on vous
accueillera dans notre méditation
collective je vous dis à demain j'espère
que ça va bien se passer j'ai jamais
fait de live sur youtube
donc voilà j'espère que je le fais avec
mon téléphone
donc j'espère que ça va ça va bien
rendre quand même et donc peut-être que
la qualité vidéo sera pas folle
peut-être que la qualité de son sera pas
folle je ne sais pas à quel point je
vais vous guider je vais essayer de le
faire au mieux possible j'ai jamais
vraiment fait ça de ma vie
ou alors vraiment juste avec des petits
groupes comme ça pour rigoler je
souhaite une très bonne fin de week end
et à demain namasté voilà bon j'espère
que c'était bien j'espère c'était clair
la air va sur un petit regret